i think my my great laugh lately has
been diane keaton mistaking your son for
leonardo dicaprio oh talk about beauty
leonardo dicaprio give me a break i knew
him when he was a kid
was that the best thing ever i love
diane diane gave me my second acting job
ever my whole life so
yeah i just like to sort of she saw him
on the street or what no she posted a
video of all these she was talking about
like oh these men are so handsome and i
love men and one of them's my son and
she said leonardo dicaprio and i was
like diane that's my son
my favorite was
that image i don't know it was like um
he was shot for a magazine interview
magazine that is so funny it was really
cute it was it was great and your kid's
getting to do the ivy park camp he's the
one who sent it to me he was like mom
this lady diane keaton like who's this
lady
her response to you was my favorite
though she just did the open while like
back like ooh that's your son sorry
how was that your kids getting to do the
ivy park campaign oh yeah they oh my god
are you kidding me they got called to do
the ivy park even deegan or in the ivy
park campaign this year that's very
exciting
[Music]
i thought they were going to pass out
they were so excited they went together
they did it together yeah it's kind of
like beyonce's version of like
college i guess okay what kids in
college dress like and it's it's really
it's good
guys we're on right now
stop i need big shows big ideas so
you're both moms i'm sure you sing
around the house so is the reaction from
the kids like hey mom or is it like ooh
mom
when you're singing around there
oh my god um i do this dumb thing where
i'm on the treadmill and i sing like
parts of songs because i have my
earphones really loud so i'm like huh
like everybody makes fun of me
it's like you're such a dork
i love it and like if you're gonna sing
just sing the whole song right
right
what about you do your kids join in or
is it like emma um
yeah it's the little one and i sing a
lot all the time i've always sing a lot
i sing a lot at work i sing all the time
my daughter it's really funny because i
sing a lot of songs like when i was
growing up i watched a lot of
rogers and hammerstein musicals and so i
sing a lot of these songs that are like
from the 40s and 50s and whatever and
then but my daughter also now sings them
just because i sing them a lot but like
she she doesn't the lyrics are all kind
of weird and it's just it's just
absolutely hilarious like just to hear
her
singing what she thinks you know is
something from i don't know it could be
like oklahoma or whatever and yeah she's
it's a pretty great that's cute listen
you guys i have a dream of performing in
red shore city since i was a little kid
one of the themes that i think well
there's so many themes in the in this
movie but one of the themes i was able
to appreciate as an adult watching it is
rosita's story and that was number one
like you know really having belief in
yourself thinking you can do it but also
having the support of your family i just
convinced my husband to babysit for the
next 24 hours and i'm not gonna waste an
opportunity like that and also i love
the theme of having the male really
supporting his wife and supporting the
female so how much i know you know you
relying on your family means everything
to you so how much does that you know in
real life mean to you as well oh my gosh
it's everything like i can't go into the
world and be creative and do my work if
i don't have support from my husband and
who scarlet actually knows really well
um but yeah it's everything and i you
know i hope it's a really great example
and modeling for people out there
because
moms have dreams too they're absolutely
you know they're they're full fully
human beings with you know um
with their own worlds and desires and i
think this really
kind of humanizes the mom even though
it's a pig no we love rosita we we love
her and i think i was reading when you
were in conversation with gayle for i
think it's um december's issue is it in
style or one of the things yeah where
you said i don't even think my kids know
how much space they take up in my head
oh my god isn't that the truth i always
think it's like the cnn ticker tape at
the bottom it's like oh how's ava doing
how's he can do it okay how's he doing
oh how's eva doing how's deacon do it's
just constantly all day long are you
like that yeah i mean i it's great
because my daughter will also say things
to me like it'll be the one time i
forgot the one thing and she's like you
don't even care i'm like girl if you
knew like all that i i mean like oh my
god
wake up what if i wake up and have to
pee like immediately i'm like thinking
of all this stuff it's like whether it's
a school it's her future it's her
feelings or whatever you're just you
know you're on and
i think that's just
that's it you have a kid and then you're
like that forever like i don't think it
ever i think that's you know we i never
knew that obviously when until you have
your own children you always wonder like
why your parents are like call me more
and whatever you're like oh that's so
annoying and then you realize oh wait
they're just thinking about me all the
time and it just never goes away
and here she is
the star of our show
rosita oh my gosh
reese you said
uh that you that this movie is the one
that people come up to you and mention
the most right oh for sure but do you
like legally blonde
hi i'm elle woods and this is freezer
woods
and we're both gemini vegetarians
more than like yeah yes
this movie like 400 billion million
people have seen this movie yes and it's
like it's multi-generational as well you
get like your grandma the kids everybody
else's kids everybody loves it yeah that
is true you get it a ton too yeah oh
yeah well of course i mean when my
daughter was she was like prime age when
the first thing came out she was like
three or four or something like that so
it was it was everything like all the
kids all the parents
my parents the grandparents it's yeah i
was gonna say for my sanity i don't even
want to call it a kids movie because
when i came out of watch i just it's so
fantastic and i was so happy you know
and i'm thinking like this is what we
need right now for me people to go into
a theater or watch it at home and come
out and just be like damn i feel good
yeah you know what i'm saying i heard
yesterday i had a screening and
everybody was singing along that just
like oh it touched my heart i like that
now scarlett tell me that you were able
to have a moment with bono record
together with him please
[Music]
i wish that was the case but at the time
and i'm sure you had the situation too
but we were all so isolated because it
was in the mid like in the beginning of
the quarantine i i knew i like when they
told me i was singing stuck in a moment
i was like you don't you have to send me
the demo i actually know the song
um very well like my 13 year old dream
come true how amazing yeah it was like
it was just it was surreal i mean what
the surreal thing is that i
obviously recorded it and like did it
with garth and it felt very intimate and
all that stuff but then
i never got to hear then i finally heard
like bono and like our duet and it was
kind of it was mind-blowing garth sent
it to me and i was like
and then he told me that he would that
like he would send somebody for me if i
ever like played it for anybody else
he's like i'm coming for you
was there ever a dream in your head like
that that would be a moment that you
have
a duet with mono in a dream not like a
wildest dream ever like in my yeah i
mean in the sh like in and when i'm
singing in the shower
i hear bono in in my mind but no i mean
because i'm also not you know what it's
funny i did i was talking with tori
kelly earlier today and she's duetted
with like
the great like stevie wonder like all
these amazing people
and you know so people are like who's
your dream person did you do it with and
she had all these and then they asked me
and i was like i don't do it like i'm
not a duet er
um this was huge yeah it's just yeah
it's it's crazy sing three where can
buster and the gang go
like wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait we just barely finished this we're
ready for another
but do you ever think about like where
they can go next they can go anywhere
they're cartoons
and they're in space
that's what i always said right
[Music]
you